hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
Anna just checking in on you little
Tarzan little Tarzan very little Johnny
Weis remember that guy that's back when
bean and shape was just not like being
fat
Johnny Mouse Millie was an Olympic
swimmer and even he was yanking his
[ __ ] whatever the hell he had to his
little fig leaf over his junk he yanked
it up past his navel nobody I challenge
you to find one person who was shirtless
back then you could actually see their
belly button now I don't know if that
was because the navel was considered
nudity back then or lewd or the devil's
work the porthole to to I don't know get
in some point I don't know I have no
idea I don't pretend to know these
things why didn't I take out my [ __ ]
Invisalign why didn't I take it I forgot
to take the [ __ ] [ __ ] out I am on
tray number 11 11 Oh 13 tray 11 and 13
is an interesting story about tray
number 11 okay I brought it to New York
alright because I went back to do the
Patrice O'Neal the sixth annual Patrice
O'Neal benefit and which by the way I
think that was probably the best one we
had as far as everybody murdered just a
perfect mix of people that knew him
people that were fans of them black
white male female few stories about
Patrice comics [ __ ] on each other
floss took a [ __ ] pounding he hosts
it I don't know what he was wearing he
had this Bing Crosby hat on then he had
like this flannel like I'm gonna go see
Pearl Jam's shirt on but he buttoned it
all the way up you know like they were
gonna we were joking like they were
gonna reboot that movie colors and then
he had like these red plastic shoes on
that he swore were the [ __ ] I don't know
what it was just one of those deals
where it's just like rich you have to
take one of
sings off if you're gonna button up the
flannel and have red shoes on get rid of
the hat or if you're gonna keep the Hat
get rid of the shoes if you're gonna
wear the shoes in the Hat put on a
different [ __ ] shirt alright but rich
vos is not a smart man
okay he's driven he's dedicated but he's
not always on the right track and this
was one of these evenings and we tried
to tell him he took a good pounding
Keith Robinson actually just showed up
just to trash people he went backstage
and Jim Norton was just minding his own
business
eating something and Keith slapped the
food right out of his [ __ ] hand onto
the floor you know the usual maturity
but I want to thank everybody that came
down in the crowd and all the comics Sam
J who I had never seen before
[ __ ] murdered P Cory le rich vos
cypher sounds DJ dit thank you so much
Jim Norton Dave Attell as always ah the
teen idol sensation from the late great
Opie and Anthony show Robert Kelly my
old roommate from back in the day
Jessica Kirsten Greer Barnes and Maureen
Tarrant for putting the whole thing
together thank you and thank you to
everybody who came out it was just a
[ __ ] awesome show just an awesome
show by all of them they had me pacing I
had to go on after most of them there
and it's just oh no no no what did I do
what did I just do you can't even
[ __ ] lean back in this goddamn place
is it still recording it is recording
but I can't hear myself oh Jesus
wish they had phone there it is gonna
plug it now most people would [ __ ]
edit that out most people are too afraid
to look foolish on their own [ __ ]
podcast where it's just them and they
play the producer and all of that
[ __ ] but not me not me so I just I
had the perfect [ __ ] time you know I
did the West Side comedy club tuned up
there the night before just so happened
Jerry Seinfeld came down so I've got to
watch him do his set absolutely crushed
such a great comedy club right it's on
75th and Broadway and between Broadway
and Amsterdam it's literally right next
to the Beacon Theater and
[ __ ] love that place thank you to the
stand for doing the after-party and all
that as they always do I might be in New
York next week and I'll be down the
stand I'll let you guys know all right
plowing ahead so it's the perfect night
everything's go straight we all hang out
down the stand afterwards they're always
so generous they've always hosted the
after-party they given everybody food
and all this [ __ ] just being the the
great guys that they are and so the end
of the night comes I go home and I'm
thinking what an absolute perfect two
days in New York and and I even
remembered I was because I was wearing
tray number 10 I even remembered tray
number 11 because Wednesday's is when I
got to put the new one in so the next
day I wake up I already booked myself a
car service which I always forget to
[ __ ] do I break open the bag I put
tray number 11 in it's always hearts the
first couple of days right I also did
the Jim and Sam show had a great time on
that just making sure I thank everybody
so anyways I put the [ __ ] trays in
and then I was like well you know I'm
dying a thirst here the car is coming so
let me just have a nice light breakfast
so I go across the street I buy a
[ __ ] orange and a big thing of water
so I take the invisalign out I'll
[ __ ] eating the orange and all that
[ __ ] right because you can't eat with
these things in unless you're an
absolute [ __ ] pig drink the water and
all that [ __ ] and then I just you know
throw all the [ __ ] out right and all
that type of stuff throw it down the
[ __ ] shoot grab my bags I'm ready to
go I still got ten minutes to spare and
then I'm looking for the Invisalign
where the [ __ ] is it I'm like oh no
please tell me
I just didn't throw it down that [ __ ]
garbage chute with everybody else's
garbage from the building please tell me
I didn't [ __ ] do that whether I threw
it down the [ __ ] shoot sound like now
what do I do I can put the old tray back
in so my teeth don't move or anything
like that and maybe I could go home and
put tray number 12 and that's what the
[ __ ] I'll do [ __ ] it it's gone I'm not
going down and digging those [ __ ]
things out of the trash I'm not [ __ ]
too
right and then I just sat there and I
was like you know what my wife would she
tell me to go down and go get it and
[ __ ] just [ __ ] soaked it in
Listerine for a day so I'm like [ __ ] all
right I'll do it
I'm gonna do it and I [ __ ] go
downstairs right
do you remember pee-wee Herman when he
ran out of the pet store with the snakes
that's what I was like so it went down
then the super was there and we [ __ ]
fortunately no one threw any trash on
top of it and they was sitting right on
top like I had a pizza box or something
like that one of them was in the pizza
box again one was sitting right on top
like a [ __ ] prize but still right so
I just took him and threw him in my bag
and then I came home I rinsed him off
scrubbed him with this brush I have and
then I just threw him in Listerine full
like overnight and then said all right
I'm gonna pop these in the mouth my
mouth and hopefully I don't get
something [ __ ] growing in my
intestines so that's it pretty gross huh
from a guy who always sits there talking
about people that [ __ ] walk barefoot
into a public bathroom on a plane I
actually fished my Invisalign [ __ ]
trays out of the trash from my [ __ ]
building then I'm so ashamed I had to
admit it but that's how dedicated I am
not Jesus Christ
they seems fine man you know then you
know I don't spill anything nothing
growing in my mouth been wearing them
for like a day or so dared to everything
seems fine I know it's embarrassing but
you know what what was I gonna die
didn't want to [ __ ] jump to the next
goddamn tray I wasn't gonna wait for
another one I want this thing to be over
alright this is how Wars at one so there
you go now everybody knows now the world
knows how disgusting a [ __ ] human
being I am whatever what dedicated
there's all different ways that you can
look at it so anyways I flew back on
JetBlue which is the [ __ ] unless your TV
isn't work
and everybody else's is that was my
experience but I still had that I still
had the you know the chair bed thing
going on and I just sat there sort of
stretch of my [ __ ] arm because the
right shoulders actually starting to
come around it's starting to come around
but I've been so goddamn busy I missed
all the Olympics Oh what's the matter
she upset now it's getting that time
it's getting to be that time a night had
a busy day today but I've been so busy
oh Jesus you're gonna hear a crying she
just had a [ __ ] little episode there
we got my daughter's ears pierced I
didn't want to [ __ ] do it but you
know whatever I guess since this is a
good time to do it cuz they don't
remember I don't know why she has to get
her ears pierced ooh [ __ ] 1 years of
age like what is she read in the news
you know is she presenting at an award
show can we just get clip on once what
is the rush
so anyways now Nia has to clean around
you know where they pierced the year you
know so she just went to do that she's
given Lola bath and Lola doesn't like it
so she tried to duck out of the way and
she put her face right in the water and
she did not enjoy so anyways
and I was I gonna say also I missed all
the Olympics but I you know I thought
the gold medal game for the ladies was
tonight in hockey evidently it was last
night in congratulations to the women of
the United States of America for winning
the the Olympic hockey gold medals for
the first time since I think like 1998
or some [ __ ]
I don't know what that's right and it
when we couldn't have beat a better
opponent and I'm not talking about the
Russians all right we only compete with
the Russians when it comes to blowing up
the whole world but when it really comes
down to hockey okay it's all about
beating Canada and I actually call cuz
I'm called up Vancouver today because
I'm doing some gigs up there and I did
the radio and they were all [ __ ] up
they were all upset about it that's why
I love Canada that's how much they care
they even care about women's hockey you
know which item not like I have anything
against it but you know down here it's
all about the men what are the men doing
we don't care what women are doing
unless it's porn or they're playing
volleyball and that's basically how it
works in this country I'm not saying
that's right
okay but that that is how it is okay
women's tennis every once in a while
does well you know I don't know I don't
know why I don't know why it is okay
it's just the way it is it's all about
that stuff so wait I call these people
up up there and Vancouver over there and
they're all like oh you bear called the
end of the game I loved it I was loved
it I was that sick we want the [ __ ]
better next we're taking the Canadian
men's team is next I know we already
lost we got bounced out by
Czechoslovakia I believe I believe
that's what happened I bet the [ __ ]
men's gold medals tonight I probably
should be watching that [ __ ] but this
year kind of sucked cuz they didn't let
the [ __ ] NHL players play the NHL was
like one of y'all going to make some
money Nazi Olympics once you will
continue to skate for us I actually you
know something
I'm not even give the NHL [ __ ] for doing
that because they actually did it for a
couple of Olympics in a row they would
just shut down the league you know what
I mean and just eat all that money and I
can tell you right now there's no
[ __ ] way the NFL would have done that
if football became a [ __ ] Olympic
sport right there's no way they'll be
like Vivian Allianz the players if
they're going to get concussed they are
going to do it by they make us the money
okay I think we'll give you some scabs
so anyways congratulations to the US a
women for winning the gold medal in
hockey and
I'm gonna sing them a song now all right
congratulations to you you beat the
Canadian lays you can't dafuq it ass
even though I miss the game I don't
wanna hear about those bad [ __ ] calls
at the end of the game put your wine and
your [ __ ] maple [ __ ] are [ __ ] are
better than yours I didn't mean to say
[ __ ] I needed a word with one civil
syllable go [ __ ] yourselves and
congratulations to the ladies sorry how
was that was that better than Fergie I
actually didn't think that Fergie one
was that bad I actually watched it on
the Jim and Sam show and I thought was
gonna be horrible I didn't mind it she
kind of did I read round one [ __ ] word
you know what I mean so I forgive him
and Rockets red glare area she did
something like that I don't know what
that part was about the rest of it I
thought was fine
I thought it was totally fine anyway
speaking of me too
I just feel like for me - when's that
gonna happen I just feel like for me
yeah I wasn't [ __ ] in a cab in Times
Square and I'm looking out the windows
I'm driving and there was this woman
with a fat ass and thick thighs wearing
black leather pants as tight as possibly
could be just walking up the street and
I know the woman's just like it's like
what are you doing in Times Square are
you out of your [ __ ] mind why don't
you just hang raw meat around your neck
and jump in shark-infested waters you
know at some point at some point you got
to be looking out for yourself right
you know she looked [ __ ] amazing but
she was by herself
late at night New York City Times Square
is that what you want to be wearing
she's probably a cop
maybe I got a bunch of me two cops out
there right now you know trying to get
the meat to guys then how it works I
don't [ __ ] know what do you want for
me okay I just sang a [ __ ] the wrong
national anthem congratulating the women
and accidentally called them away you
know I call them [ __ ] right in jest
I'm sure somebody with hairy legs is
gonna get upset by that
and then that's that's how it works okay
I know there's a lot of [ __ ] problems
out there right now and then people
don't like being being whatever they
call it
hooting and hollering Adam why they call
it they call what a woman walks down the
street and every guys I know but where
they call it can't call it and all that
[ __ ] you know I'm sure that's upsetting
all right but you know I would be lying
if I didn't tell you I was a little
jealous okay because when I walk by a
construction site all I hear is the
sound of men working you don't think I'd
like a standing ovation every once in a
while you know every once in a while get
a little shout out make you put a little
pep in your step
I'm [ __ ] with you I don't have any
advertising this week can you believe it
after all the [ __ ] I've said they're
slowly backing away slowly back in a way
I should adjust my tone guess what my
[ __ ] drum room is finally done I
built add this person build me a drum
room in the [ __ ] garage and turned
out that was still just a little bit too
loud I learned a lot of things like 30
decibels it's basically the sound of a
silent room with like a light on like
the little buzz of a light bulb all
right that's the 30 decibels queefing is
35 I read on all of this okay like 50 to
it's like a light rain you know 70 I
forget what the [ __ ] that is and the 90s
when it starts getting annoying so my
room was built and I was still at 70
right outside the garage he walked up
the driveway you couldn't hear it too
much buzz I can't have it all right so I
had somebody else come in and they added
this extra [ __ ] to it and then today
it's just like it's the [ __ ] right
outside the garage door is basically the
sound of a light rain and you go up the
driveway you can't even [ __ ] hear it
so I have the dream [ __ ] drum room I
can if I could play at 2:00 in the
morning and even when you stood outside
the garage all you can really hear is
like the snare drum and it just sort of
sounds like somebody has a stereo one a
little bit low it's [ __ ] perfect it's
[ __ ] perfect so that's gonna be
what's gonna keep me sane I think over
the next few years as the orange guy in
the hairless fat dude sit there pointing
[ __ ] missiles at each other you know
what I mean
Trump and what's-his-face they're a
little mush face I don't know what they
just go [ __ ] hang out already you
know have one of those [ __ ] online
dates you know I mean just discuss like
oppressing people huh
just kind of compare notes you know and
then maybe they could like combine what
it is that they both do I'm out of my
[ __ ] my people I don't pay attention
to anything somebody actually said to me
did you hear about so-and-so with like
the Russians and all that [ __ ] and I was
like I'm gonna be perfectly honest to
you I did not know did they do a probe
and and what's gonna happen is he going
to get impeached and then what let me
guess it's gonna go to the [ __ ] the
the place where all the people in the
suit sit and then they're gonna need 3/4
of a vote and nobody Republican will
vote for it and then it'll still be in
office it's not what's gonna happen I
seem to remember that's what happened
that time that guy took this
ya know Slick Willy all Slick Willy
anyways yeah I don't pay attention to
that [ __ ] it's just not uh I don't find
it interesting that weird the fact that
I actually find sports interesting which
are real but don't really matter but the
actual [ __ ] that's going on like this
guy could get in that level of trouble I
don't give a [ __ ] I hope them people
keep Isetta me [ __ ] in about the about
gun control or no gun control or a
reasonable gun control because I find
all of that fascinating I guess all the
kids are gonna get together then they're
gonna do some big protests and I like
how people who are into guns are going
these kids are coached they totally
being coached right that's the exact
thing that nobody needs you know I'm not
saying that both sides aren't gonna try
to like [ __ ] finesse their whole angle
or whatever and that there won't be
somebody coach but you should probably
listen to people you know I want to know
what I could come fascinated with the
[ __ ] ar-15 right I mean I might buy
one before they get [ __ ] banned just
because it'll be worth money you know
what I mean
like when people buy like you know when
they reissued the Jordans and people buy
them they don't wear them and they just
stick them in the back of the closet so
just one day they can just bust it out
never he's like oh [ __ ] right I want to
know people who have a ar-15s I know
there's people listen this podcast you
got one let me ask you this what do you
do with it okay I know what I would do
with it okay I wouldn't take it down to
some stupid [ __ ] gun range and like
dude like target practice that's not
what you get that gun for you get that
gun to reenact safely the end of
Scarface so if I had an ar-15 what I
would do every year around Halloween I
wait a couple days after when
everybody's pumpkins are getting all
mushy and I would just knock on the door
and be like you want me to take that off
your heads I'll take your old pumpkins
right you know I put up a sign old
pumpkins recycled here right and I get a
whole fill up the whole back into my
truck with a bunch of old pumpkins
right and then I would [ __ ] I just
take them out some field right I got an
ar-15 you know I live in the middle of
nowhere right I'd [ __ ] take them out
into a field
I put wigs on them and [ __ ] maybe a
little suit underneath depending how far
I wanted to get with it you know and
then just [ __ ] light them up other
than that what the [ __ ] do you have it
for that's like these [ __ ] who get
like a Ferrari and now they just drive
it up and down the Sunset Strip it's
like [ __ ] put it on a truck take it
to a track and drive it the way it's
supposed to be driven you know I mean
that's what I would do that's what the
[ __ ] I mean if you got it don't you want
to do that you can't tell me somebody
anonymously right in and just tell me
the stupidest [ __ ] thing you did with
your ar-15 just having fun you know or
if my neighbor pissed me off when they
weren't around I just [ __ ] shooting
into the side of his [ __ ]
above-ground pool right I would do silly
[ __ ] he'd fire an ar-15 I wouldn't hurt
anybody else
destruction of property you know yeah I
would do that but you know women are
allowed to get away with that take their
[ __ ] ex-husbands [ __ ] and light it on
fire or a [ __ ] cheating boyfriend
throw it out in the [ __ ] yard you
know stab it all up cops come down
laughs and they don't give a [ __ ] that
woman goes back in the house they don't
care they don't give a [ __ ] why can't a
man go out every once in a while and
just shoot somebody's above-ground pool
with an ar-15 is that it isn't there a
real while you got to make sure there's
nobody in it right it's also a waste of
water it's irresponsible but you know
what I mean you can't tell me if there
was a YouTube video of it you wouldn't
want to see it all right and then scroll
down and look at all the comments like
Oh waste water much and then at me a
petty but liberal smells like a mothball
you live out there and all
in desert a couple more comments
somebody drops the n-word you know the
basic conversation on YouTube right
that's what I do anyways so I don't have
any [ __ ] advertising I don't have any
[ __ ] emails and I got six more
minutes to go
can he do it can he think of something
that he can [ __ ] talk about for the
next six minutes
what about why do I don't got to think
about something what about [ __ ] you
just sitting there listening huh the
next six minutes your life is gonna go
by you know and you're gonna sit there
you're gonna sit there waiting for me to
try to come up with something to say
aren't you that's what you're at Aenon
gone not non-gun people all right
the people want to get rid of all the
guns do they want to get rid of all the
guns can you do that
isn't that trying to like get rid of all
the straws like how would you do that
it's like they're out there people come
in like yeah these are all the straws I
have how would you know that
you know straws are made out of plastic
everybody which means evidently they
never break down so they just think well
the way the first time you went to
[ __ ] McDonald's my god Carl Carl
chocolate shake just think of the fact
that that cup is long gone because was
made out of paper
but that straw that you [ __ ] drank
out of with that little thing on top
it's still [ __ ] there it's somewhere
it's in the ground it's out the [ __ ]
ocean just swirling around that's the
type of [ __ ] I think about you know with
all these minimalist people got on the
[ __ ] minimalist it's like what do you
do with all your [ __ ] you just throw it
out so now you don't have to look at it
you know went somewhere right that's why
you gotta have a [ __ ] yard sale Jesus
Christ just open yourself up to a bunch
of [ __ ] cheap [ __ ] now maybe they're
environmentalists some of the [ __ ] that
they have out there you know this is so
many [ __ ] fishes invisalign out of a
goddamn
communal trash bin earlier this week is
literally gonna sit here and judge
people that go to yard sales and try to
find gems you know it's really going
away as those stores where you just have
that [ __ ] like a hoarder
he just has all this random [ __ ] and
they're like a [ __ ] up lamp and an old
cash register next to like a propeller
for some [ __ ] plane you know what
were those kinds of store get night
antiques it's night he's beyond antiques
it's like modern antiques it's just
plastic [ __ ]
you know that nobody [ __ ] once
there's be a guy down the street for me
he dealt all in speakers and [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] dude crazy
crazy [ __ ] I went in there one
time and I had these iPod speakers that
I wanted to fixed and he started telling
me that he had this revolutionary way
that he was going to record music and he
was trying to tell me he used Simon and
Garfunkel as an example saying nobody
really knows what they sound like
even if they've heard the recordings
because they weren't recorded correctly
because Garfunkel is like a foot taller
than Paul Simon so if you were standing
in the room Garfunkel's boys would be
coming at you from you know eight to 12
inches higher than Paul Simon's voice
and the way that that would reverberate
around the [ __ ] room would be what
they actually sounded like whereas when
they go to record him it makes him sound
like they're both the same height and
I'm just sitting there listening this
guy going this guy's out of his [ __ ]
mind but he also might be on to
something
so he was trying to explain to me how
the [ __ ] he was gonna record that and I
was just like you know what as much as
this guy seems like he's out of his
[ __ ] mind he's so into this [ __ ] he's
gonna be able to fix these speakers and
you know what he took my speakers you
know and set him behind the cash
register whatever were I just saw a wall
of speakers anywhere from [ __ ] I
don't know 10 years old to 40 50 years
old all behind him he was like Sanford
and Son
junkyard and it was all [ __ ] speakers
and I'm sorry and I got that dumb sound
effect it's the only way I can hear if
somebody [ __ ] since we had text that
gumshoe when and anyway so he takes my
speakers and you know what he does he
never [ __ ] fix them and I kept
calling him up he didn't even know where
the [ __ ] they were and I never got him
back and he said drive by his store for
two years being like that [ __ ]
got my speakers and he's gonna find one
of these [ __ ] at a yard sale to give
him like 25 bucks for it
one of these days when I got the time
I'm gonna go in there and be like hey
man never we took my speakers and he
didn't give me a piece of paper or any
sort of proof that actually gave you
speakers and you've talked to another
three million people since I came in the
place well guess what I'm back without
any proof but I'm telling you got my
speakers in here somewhere and I want
him back I was so meaning to do that and
I never I never got around to it and one
day I drove by and it was just didn't
exist anymore
so you know what that means right unless
this guy took all that [ __ ] my [ __ ]
speakers right now I probably in the
middle of the Pacific Ocean floating
around floating around and like swirling
and swirling and eventually they're
gonna run into that straw that I had at
mcdonnell's and now you know the rest of
the story I'm sorry did that take six
minutes 29 seconds to go Jesus Christ
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] I got to get
caught up in the Bruins I guess we we
made some we've made some moves at the
trade deadline we've got some defenseman
from the [ __ ] is that from the New York
Rangers I guess they just packing it in
they said to hell with it does that mean
they're gonna get rid of half Henrik
Lundqvist you know they can't do that
mention the overhead of that guy [ __ ]
shipping all those suits to some other
town and where would he wear cue magic
of Henrik Lundqvist ever got [ __ ]
like he got traded to like Columbus you
know with all his GQ GQ clothes walking
around [ __ ] Columbus it'll give a
[ __ ] they barely give a [ __ ] about
hockey out there right they're all
the Iowa State Buckeyes know that's
actually good hockey town I went out
there one time for a Red Wings game
playoff game and it was [ __ ] great
Columbus and Nashville crazy fans great
fans however not exactly the kind of
place where you gonna wear Henrik
Lundqvist can wear some of his fancy
suits you know that's a pretty confident
move to buy suits like that as a
professional athlete you know where you
probably thinking well maybe I'll just
wear them in the offseason or [ __ ] it up
late but Columbus but I'm gonna live in
New York because goddamn it I'm gonna go
I'm gonna wear these bucket suits or
maybe you wear the suits in Columbus II
did you show people what the next level
looks like I don't know I'm talking
about they're not even thinking about
trading him but all I know is we got a
defenseman out of it and we gave up a
couple of draft picks or whatever and I
don't know the Bruins are like hey they
got the second most points I'd barely
watch the game this year cuz I got a
little kid and I'm edited in the [ __ ]
series I did four hours today with the
great Laura Dern she absolutely [ __ ]
murdered today she does the voice of Sue
Frank's wife and I'm telling the seasons
coming together I think I'm going to
talk a little [ __ ] here I think this
might be our best season I think this is
the season where we finally break out of
the pack and we get invited to one of
them [ __ ] shows and they give us some
shiny [ __ ] and we all go up in a big
group hug you know and we enjoy it for
eight seconds before they take it away
from us and they say get back in that
room and do it again
alright that's the podcast sorry I got a
little [ __ ] nuts they're just trying
to fill time I said a lot of things I
meant very little little of it okay but
that doesn't matter in this day and age
what your job is to do now is to take it
seriously and start talking about how
offended you were and ignore real
problems and talk about this podcast as
if it said swirling trashing all right
that's the parking test here
[Music]
sorry my brains [ __ ] fried
that's the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
have a great weekend you [ __ ] enjoy
this music and I'll do a little trumping
with the index finger and the thumb that
make them look points here and then
we're gonna play a little bit of
throwback [ __ ] Thursday podcast
Afghan podcasts from Thursday from this
year or years before I have no [ __ ]
idea
oh by the way I almost forgot to say are
you going to bed little cutie hi are you
adorable is it even legal to be that
cute yeah do you know something as far
as business goes you ever see somebody
make a business move and you think why
didn't I think of that yeah alright
here's my latest one do you know
barstool sports yeah they're huge
they're huge do you know what they
bought there's some sort of like
fighting I figure what's even called
it's just like this regular person
fight night it's started and I believe
Virginia and just regular people go up
there just throwing haymakers beating
the S out of each other sorry my kids
here beating the crap out of each other
and it's just you know haymakers very
little technique and then they got
haymaker is a maker is actually an
expression that came from farming and I
think it was when you took the sickle
and you just swung from behind you to
chop it down I looked it up one time
so anyways hey why don't you take the
microphone I got this I'll get this
simple like I got this all set let me
just finish this real quick so these
regular people come in and that the
fights are crazy okay because these
people are just swinging for the fences
and eventually somebody connects with
somebody I'm not saying they're all bad
but it's just like this crazy it's like
I don't it's like barroom brawls
okay so barstool sports bought it and
then they put it on pay-per-view it's
like if you if you order it early it's
ten bucks
mm-hmm
who isn't gonna buy that and how aren't
you gonna get your money back are those
people that coming in to fire do they
get paid they get I don't know what they
get I don't think there's want to be on
TV I have no idea I don't know it works
I don't care about them it's all about
me ten bucks Nia okay I'm ordering that
I don't know when the next one is but I
am ordering that and that's one of those
things what that is gonna turn into like
it's gonna be like the regular person
UFC and I guarantee you sometime that's
good that's gonna sell for tens of
million if not hundreds of millions of
dollars calling it right now regular
Rogan said one time if you just driving
down the street and if you see two
people beat the crap out of each other
you'd slow down and look at it what did
you rather watch professionals who have
trained and have techniques and have
moves no I was I would appreciate both
yeah yeah because this is the thing even
though they're not professionals they're
really fighting and people really get
knocked out mm-hmm and this is the thing
there's none of that as far as I could
tell just eclipse I watched there's none
of that ground-and-pound strategy it's
just people it's like because they're
all just like no they're not I would not
want to get hit by any of the punches I
saw thrown right is this like that but
[ __ ] that like Kimbo Slice used to do
like at the backyard like guys now I saw
was highlights I was just it was like
Jerry Springer
if you edit it out all the crap and you
just had the fights yeah well cool all
right maybe you're the wrong demographic
yeah I could I finally was saying
something positive on the goddamn
podcast I couldn't be less interested
and yeah you don't want to give us smoke
a joint just watch that I'll have a
little sippy cup I'm gonna watch UFC or
boxing and sup I guess I could get into
that I don't know there's I here's what
we're gonna do the next one of those
we're gonna rent we're gonna
and then you're gonna come back on the
podcast and talk about it please all
right you know what it is nice nice baby
it feels exploitative to me that's why I
asked if the people who are doing it or
getting paid I'm sure they get it
probably on some tough man parts in the
end of it cuz it's like there's they're
there selling it for like $10 each these
people their whole thing is that they're
like not professional so it's not like
they're gonna go on to have her career
and fighting so what are they yeah
here's the thing because if they win
make sure she doesn't take that make
sure she doesn't take that she's pulling
it off I don't think she can get it out
can you just thank you
she pushed it all the way into the
keyhole all right I don't well I was
excited I was excited about you got to
see it yet it's it's still people
fighting the people that you have
Cicotte day they get exploited do you
think they're making the lion's share of
the money they're the ones taking the
concussions and all that there's been
plenty of fighters have been in the UFC
that talked about the same thing yeah
you get to be on TV and if you win you
know you knock somebody out you're on TV
and that's pretty cool okay sure
cool it's you know it's like it's like
American Idol none of those people have
no business singing on television but
what they do and they get to do that
right okay is that all right yeah but do
they have a referee like do they have
somebody that's like don't kill agent
just really you just why are you coming
at this like a mother who cares we don't
know these people it's entertaining yes
there's a referee and there's two
hilarious announcers I have become
really soft since having the baby that's
it's been a beautiful thing to see I'm
so soft now I'm just like you know as
she do want to push up she's she's doing
something okay are you ready look at
those cheeks loves being in here yes she
does
what are you talking about I love when
she just cracks herself up what are you
thinking about all right this is this
kids too cute I gotta get off here I
gotta say goodnight to my girl here all
right thanks for coming yet let's see
here's a deal the next one that comes on
provided I'm not working even if I'm
working I'm I'm ordering it okay we're
gonna record it we're gonna watch it all
right and I want to hear what you had to
think about it I'm 100% willing to do
that okay I won't because I'm gonna
those guys whoever those guys are that
that run that thing that they are going
to make and an effing fortune off of
that I think it's gonna I think it's
going to blow up as you were excited
about to see Black Panther and you're
literally doing the exact opposite all
right that's the podcast thank you for
listening everybody and I will talk to
you on Monday
[Music]
what has happened to sports can't wait
ESPN can we you know 100% access can you
dial it back down to like maybe 40%
access
can you stop interviewing [ __ ]
coaches Fox and whatever NBC is they're
jogging off the field trying to think of
their halftime adjustments can we just
stop [ __ ] doing that I don't give a
[ __ ]
NHL can we stop interviewing players in
between the [ __ ] periods is this
sitting there still out of breath from
their last shift and that [ __ ] drop a
[ __ ] sweat hanging off their nose
looking like snot that they have to keep
wiping and then it comes back again can
we just enough I don't give a [ __ ] what
happened in that first period I just
watched the first period I know what
happened what do you think you have to
do in the second period Oh baby school
little goals if any NHL players listen
to this I'll give you a free podcast
t-shirt even though you're gonna get
fined probably a hundred grand by the
league is there any way you could wipe
your nose on the blouse of the person
who's interviewing you in between
periods just reach out and grab it I
just dab your eyes you know I got
nothing to give you you're a millionaire
athlete but could you just do it for the
just for the [ __ ] ridiculousness of
it like they're not going to interview
you after the [ __ ] game like I have
to have it they got that [ __ ] guy who
stands down there and what looks like
the penalty box in between the [ __ ]
benches whatever the [ __ ] his name is
Prince Fielder fails his name
Prince Harry standing down there without
a trace that ate up down here the ice
like why do I need to hear that guy
well bass has got to stand up for three
periods and his loafers it's probably
got hammer toes by the end of the year
let's access do you think you could do
that do you think you could actually
start a sports network that could
compete with ESPN and the whole thing is
less access you know no miked up players
you just [ __ ] uh just trim the fat I
just go back to watch a Bob Lobel at the
end of the news and just seeing five
minutes of the [ __ ] can I just see that
as he sits there in a [ __ ] blazer you
know every once awhile takes a day off
and new me comes in Bob knew Maya I miss
those days I really miss the [ __ ] day
[Music]
dushaan Southwest so um I went to
Albuquerque this weekend and I had a
[ __ ] unbelievable time have not been
back there since all those wonderful
episodes of Breaking Bad that I got to
be on and you know I was gonna go on a
hike that's what I want to do I want to
do that but uh you know Nia had some
friends out there we were gonna go to
lunch you know that is it'll only take
like an hour that's three hours you know
so I'm just like I'm too [ __ ] old too
I'm too old to [ __ ] hike and have a
social event in one day and then
actually give any sort of a decent
decent performance so I was like I
[ __ ] I'm not gonna go on the hike
I'll go over and we meant I meant he his
friends and they were they were awesome
[ __ ] cooked up burgers the middle of
the day you know those homemade burgers
that are way bigger than the ones that
you get in a restaurant and then you eat
them and you know fill 60 or some
stomach afterwards [ __ ] phenomenal
and the people's house we went over to
they had all these beers and that type
of stuff and I stayed away I was a good
boy so I could have the show but I know
myself at this point so I still that I
can't do all of those activities in one
day so I just decided like alright I'll
just do the social thing and I'll chill
out which was actually really cool cuz
I've been to Albuquerque a bunch of
times and I never got to ride around and
see any of it
and it's really really [ __ ] cool
place man really really cool
so anyway so that night I was at the the
66 casino meaning basically route 66 and
one of the coolest looking casinos I've
seen I'll try to have some images up for
you no you try to take pictures of those
casino lights and it never comes out on
your cell phone at least the one that I
have the 4f but it was really cool like
the hotel had like that you know the
route 66 sign instead of the 66 it just
said hotel it was all lit up and then
you know it's Native Americans owned it
and then the the the arrows pointing in
where to go were literally like arrows
and they look like they were stuck into
the ground they were all lit up it was
[ __ ] badass it was badass and then I
got a play in the the name of the
theater was the legends theater I played
a place called the legends theater I
remember I was doing some press for and
they said what can people expect when
they come down to the legends theater
and it's like well they should expect to
see a legend they shouldn't expect to
see me Oh fresh out of the [ __ ] horse
stable where do I go is this the way to
the great robe scared fortunately it all
went it went great and [ __ ] great
people out there man once again and this
was another place that was supposed to
be a stop on the Billy red-state tour
and I don't know for any comics who are
listening to this don't buy into that
horseshit that these are flyover States
they're beautiful places to go and the
people are ridiculously appreciative
that you showed up this psyched and they
always say the same [ __ ] can you tell
this person tell this person you know
they're always asking for Jim Norton and
all these guys that I know from the Opie
and Anthony show telling them to come
out there you know we like comedy too so
I passed the word on to them and a lot
of them have started coming out which is
cool I just hope that they don't become
an all jaded like when you play like the
bigger cities they just like whatever
whatever man you know
got other things to do man it was great
and they actually bought a bunch of DVDs
which is phenomenal because I got a
bunch of them sitting in my garage I
feel like my garage is filled with
[ __ ] laser discs I gotta get those
things out of there
anyways so oh the douche on Southwest
sorry I'm all over the place today so
we're flying back quick flight back I
own 45 minutes [ __ ] phenomenal and
you know the Southwest people they
always try to be funny put a smile on
your face most times they're not and
this guy was actually kind of funny then
we go to land
we weren't landing in Los Angeles and
this [ __ ] [ __ ] gets on the the
[ __ ] mic it starts going you know
he's like going welcome to Los Angeles
which is a interesting place yes very
interesting kept doing this weird laugh
and I'm looking at Mia first of all it
sounded creepy is [ __ ] hell I don't
want to be homophobic but the guy
sounded gay you know the gay accent so
why just do a joke on this like gay
people come from all 50 states yet they
kind of all have the same accent which
isn't true but generally speaking there
is a gay accent which makes no sense how
did that joke that's how that joke used
to go like if you were gay from Alabama
you're like hey Bonnie I'd really like
to suck your dick like that's the way
you should sound just do a stereotypical
redneck accent with my stereotypical gay
accent alright but they don't I grew up
in Alabama let's just say I'm not going
back there oh that's part more valley
girl you know what the [ __ ] I'm saying
that's what the guy sounded like so I'm
just sitting there in the back door like
did you know this guy get blown in West
Hollywood --nt somebody stole his wallet
did he want to be the next Jim Jay
Buffon's whatever the [ __ ] the guy's
name is from too close for comfort I
don't know what his [ __ ] deal was but
I'm just sitting there in my head going
let them get another that most [ __ ] up
thing about living in Los Angeles I've
never lived in a city where everybody
trashes it
everybody just shits on it and
me about that see this is the only
[ __ ] city where you could do that I
guess you can kind of make like a
gambling joke but you can actually land
in Los Angeles not give a [ __ ] that
everybody there lives on the plane for
the most part lives there and then just
[ __ ] on it
I [ __ ] drove me nuts
strive me [ __ ] is what's a
interesting place that's just sick well
what the [ __ ] are you doing what makes
you such a good person what happened to
you here huh
what sitcom did you test for and he got
two coked up the night before and you
[ __ ] blew it huh but we supposed to
be on Will & Grace there um sorry in
order this I'm defensive of LA at this
point because I have to live out here
because this is the [ __ ] business on
me I don't have to but you know it makes
life a lot [ __ ] easier to be where
everybody else is in this business you
know if I was into [ __ ] computers
I'd go move up to uh the [ __ ] the
valley up there the Silicon Valley but
for the life of me I don't know what why
do they call it silicon isn't that
what's in fake titties is it I don't
[Music]